for honor is getting a lot of attention  for its multiplayer but if you don't  want to swing swords and axes online you  can also dive into the game  single-player campaign which is said to  be a very rich experience gamespot's sat  down with creative director Jason  Vandenberg to talk about what players  can expect from single player he stated  it's a full story campaign a cinematic  adventure where you will play as the  Knights first as the warden then you  play as the Raider than you play as the  Orochi we built the campaign so that if  you bought the game just for that that  you would be satisfied even if you never  went online and played multiplayer it's  intended to be a full experience for  honour comes to ps4 xbox one in PC next  Valentine's Day februari 14 2017 you can  expect plenty more trailers in gameplay  leading up to launch day so stay tuned  to gamespot for tons of footage and for  all the biggest Ubisoft news you're  already in the right place  you